hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play amnesia rain
by kya God I don't know where that's
from but I'm betting Sweden or something
like that
everything that's foreign out of America
is from Sweden just like all of them my
furniture anyway for best experience
play at night alone with headphones at
night alone and I got headphones on so
let's go I did a recent thing on Twitter
asking what you guys thought I should
play in there a bunch of terrible
suggestions there were a bunch of
suggestions of custom stories that I've
already played and then this one which
is rated 9 so should big you did I
haven't really gotten to flex my oh it's
very nice am i playing yet are very
slowly haven't gotten to flex and
amnesia custom join I could tell I
haven't done to flex my Swedish accent
in a long time hello amnesia
brain I wonder if it has anything to do
with that storm outside no I'm hoping
for a good one because I mean it said it
was gonna have two to three hours of
gameplay so I'm hoping for a multi-part
series because I really do like amnesia
and I love the big long ones like the
thing and the things in the night and
the great work were two of the longest
ones and they were just incredible
chapter 1 dungeons
I bought it you're here early
are you gonna be plaguing me this is not
a full conversion mod but apparently you
don't even need a full conversion lot
anymore to play custom content hello
picked up a chipper and here's a note I
fear my life is in peril someone or
something is keeping me in this cage
against my will where I am in how or how
I got here I have no relation of
recollection of Chinese me for my memory
is fragmented in my mind is scattered I
find it necessary to write down my
thoughts for fear of losing them again I
don't know how many times I have drifted
in and out of consciousness or for how
long I've been here
I see visions beyond this nightmare
visions of wood and carpet instead of
stone and dirt a year reign and I feel
compelled forth by something beyond my
ability to describe in words the hole in
the center of this hell
if cell looks to be my only way out
sorry the grammar was great for one of
the examinees of cousin stories I was
just having trouble reading hey buddy
ah oh yeah I know your Breann yeah right
walk away
[ __ ] haha I called him a [ __ ]
and he just walked away I'm so badass
okay we deadly I hate crawling in these
tunnels because I know it's a perfect
place for them to jump scare me now used
to there being watering this one hello
I think the left tunnel is usually
blocked yeah what Darius won't amar here
thank you
no thank you
don't be doing that it's nice and subtle
but I don't appreciate it right now shut
up
hello caboose key a biscuit are their
scuba lures they're on tip you snore I'm
getting to really exercise my
swedishness everyone knows that I am
part Swedish maybe Norwegian would you
believe that how about Danish Dutch ding
ding all right well we got here I need
to turn those hints off hang on I've had
those hints on for a long time and I
just I never do them okay there we go
I was thrown stuff wasting precious
resources did I I still have the hammer
and chipper there's nothing in there but
some blood and stones
hi what are you doing Oh should I run I
hear something what is it what is that
who's in there who's in there
who's there there just some body parts
here ah what is this wax role secret
Christmas what wax role say what was
this supposed to be a Christmas custom
story
there's released in February it's pretty
recent by the by oh no ok doors locked I
gotta go upstairs my running speed has
yet to be unlocked I can't run just yet
so I'm stuck moving at an even pace
hello hello guvnah oh yes because we're
all British or Swedish I don't know oh
oh oh the Queen oh hey wait this is my
cell you mean it was unlocked the whole
time I guess I didn't try it oh well
whatever bygones will be bygones they
wanted me to be free I just never took
the opportunity I've been working in the
damn prison cell with no memory of the
events that brought me here that
I have no memory whatsoever these walls
seem familiar though I don't feel
entirely lost down here my intuition is
providing me guidance and it's madness I
feel sure that I can escape from this
place I'm certain that the exit to these
dungeons through the northern prison
cells the entrance to which is not far
from here
but the door will require a key this key
is fallen into the bowels of the torture
chamber bats are I spit all over myself
how's my good impression of was that
guy's name is Omri Ulrich Ulrich yeah
that sounds pretty Swedish torture
chambers yeah Lulu licks confidence was
reassuring I feel overwhelmed by the
possibility of my escape from this
madness and so I've been imprisoned in
these halls for much longer than I
actually have maybe I'm all rigged
have I ever thought about that something
blocking it from the other side as per
yuge I have yet to get a lantern what if
I ever will
hello I didn't want a response it's
really okay that's a lot of blood
you know I mean it usually in video
games and especially anime the human
body has like 10,000 times more blood
than it should
hey come on I saw it I can't use it that
way but I would be able to bash through
this thing with a hammer and chipper all
right I tried it three times it's
obviously not gonna work I want to find
out what's in this secret Christmas wax
world
that ow and a tang no no I do like the
atmosphere this custom story so far it's
proving itself to be very nice hello
round down a dumb
someone's been questioning me calling it
loud down at dumb
I've been calling that it that forever
so I don't know where you've been
obviously not a longtime subscriber mmm
but I do like this cuffs I'm sorry
there's a lot of detail in the work and
I mean really elegant stuff that's not
you don't usually see like I love it
when people get creative with the
limited resources that are available I'm
not going that way
screw that
ah what the hell not the red goop
alright I'll go that way
fine cheese yeah it sounds good
lovely lovely torture chambers yeah when
I first came across this whole series of
Oh God I hear the amnion to chase music
why okay I found a secret key I'm out of
here apparently being in there is bad
news boohoo goodness gracious Han I got
a double check make sure there wasn't
anything else in here a chair and now my
visions gone thoroughly Wonka fide that
guy's being mert alized
and I'm getting it out of here yeah
pretty much none of these are good ways
to die but that one especially pretty
bad I mean for one they're chopping
right through your nards
so that's doubly extra bad I mean that's
that's an equal opportunities bad that's
bad for both women and men that's just
wrong Oh God
hi what were you doing there
is there another secret key in here I
don't even know what the secret key is
for I sense energy radiating from this
key it's got there's probably one in
each of these room so and just gotta
look for it hello hello hello hello I
can move those but not the whoa it got
dark hello
stop going dark on me oh what's this
what's this hang on I see this is crank
turn handle
Oh God my vision is so wonk applied
right now I'm just gonna turn this for a
bit maybe it'll release a key or
something I don't know okay no I gotta
get I can't see a damn thing I don't
know why it's suddenly stirred getting
bad wasn't bad before there's got to be
something in here right secret key maybe
maybe not I don't even know what the
secret key is for if it's for anything
like to do with the main story no
cameras anymore all right
I've looked enough I'm out of here that
stuff is getting me a headache yeah
I think I'd still pick getting my head
squished like a grape over being sawed
through the crotch oh yeah music yeah an
easy change whoa stop it
really this is fun
okay so there's something actually in
there well okay I don't want to look at
the face thank you very much
haha oh now it's stopping okay okay I
promise you know I would that's a little
bit of a secret that I wasn't supposed
to be able to us stop it ladies
seriously I get it you're trying to
scare me it worked
you can stop now okay still no secret
key maybe they're scattered throughout
the game in one more time ah for the
road okay Anna dawn dawn dawn hey were
you trying to kill me
chick alright let's see what's next
Oh double I love
yes yes the brazen boards a horrifying
amalgamation of human imagination as you
probably notice that like the word
amalgamation even though I probably
haven't been using it correctly drill my
entire let's play career alright let's
get over this I'm done with the whole
torture speech stick oh one what this is
new what is this what is this supposed
to be please note that the acid bath
it's designed for torture non execution
to this end breeze refrain fulfilling
the bass to the brim in order to
submerge the prisoners as it kills the
prisoner too quickly and leaves a mass
in the acid bath I see a connection
between misuse of this tub and the
increase of tissue in the drain
downstairs if I catch anyone using this
equipment carelessly or disposing of
waste improperly they will beyond
cleanup duty for a month sincerely the
overseer all right
that's disgusting anything over here got
me looking for secrets game
yeah me looking for secrets disgusting
secrets but secrets nonetheless it's
locked is one of the secret keys there
work for it oh hello I got the crowbar
which means I can probably open the door
at the top of the stairs but it's bound
to be some other diabolical cities the
train is now well and truly clogged from
decades of blood and tissue not even a
drop of water can pass through that
tangled mess there has been some amusing
speculation amongst some of the workers
here there there is a compressed river
of blood flowing beneath the drains
which will swallow us all up if we break
through the blockage how quaint and in
any case it's not like a bit of blood
ever hurt anyone but seriously something
needs to be done about this clogged
drain immediately someone needs to tell
the overseer
oh that was my overseer voice I I
misused it
all right so you you you that's
disgusting
well I'm glad to know that everyone is
so happy about their working environment
that they're just eager to talk about
this disgusting buildup of vile and
human remains but I must continue
forward actually I must stop soon yep
looks like I'm gonna have a little bit
of a break here so I'm all at a time for
this one this looks to be an incredible
amnesia custom store I can't wait to
play more of it I hope you guys are
looking forward to it you can play it
for yourself as always click the link in
the description below download it check
it out let me know what you think so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos it I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next week bye bye
look Jenna
ah
but
Oh
yeah